so sky have been using you guv all the
way through the corona virus epidemic to
chart the government's performance and
you can see on the graph that we've got
this morning the white line shows the
number of people that think the governor
doing well and the blue line think that
it has been the number think that it's
been doing badly now all the way along
the government has been doing incredibly
well
look lockdown was introduced on March
the 23rd Boris Johnson's approval
ratings go up peaking with 72 percent
saying the government will do well and
21 percent saying that they will do
badly the government continued to do
well through the rest of march through
all of april and at the start of May but
look now in light of the Prime
Minister's announcement last weekend
we've had crossover for the first time
more people think the government are
doing badly than say that they're doing
well 49 percent telling you gov at the
end of last week that the government was
doing badly against 47 percent who say
that they're doing well now the
government needs the public on their
side for coronavirus more than any
political issue this isn't an election
it's something far more serious so
what's going on here there's a huge age
divide broadly speaking people under 50
all of those age categories think the
government is now doing badly
whereas they've held on the support of
people over 50 and those age categories
in those age categories more people
think that they're doing well there is
also a big regional divide in London and
Scotland overall more people think the
government are doing badly there's of
course the two of the air is the country
that have been worst hit whereas
elsewhere in England and Wales actually
still more people think it's been going
well and one political warning for Boris
Johnson just over one in five people who
voted conservative into the 2019
December election now think that his
handling is poor so Sam the government
will be looking at this closely what
does it mean for them going forward so I
think the data reveals why people are
suddenly more worried and more uncertain
about the government's handling they say
they're on balance they oppose the
changes that are announced by Boris
Johnson last week
and more than half the population 54%
think that the changes relaxed things
too much that it's not a strict enough
lockdown given what's going on out in
the community but the most striking
finding in the data is that people just
don't like being told that it's up to
their common sense they want something
far more prescriptive from their
government
now 23% say the public want basic
guidance but all other questions about
how they should behave should be left up
to them up to their common sense but 73%
want something far more certain they say
73% say the public needed detailed
guidance about what to do in the commons
this week Boris Johnson put common sense
at the heart of his approach perhaps
surprisingly that's not what the public
wanted to hear